on the news other potential criminal
activity out there uh last week actually
in a bonus show segment I talked about
the fact that you have all of these fake
vaccine cards uh that are becoming more
and more prominent uh specifically in
North Carolina at the time
but it turns out just a couple days ago
Customs and Border Patrol in Tennessee
confiscated more than three thousand
fake covid vaccine cards
in fact it was 3017 cards in 121
packages the packages were labeled paper
greeting cards used for greeting card or
paper paper card
we're starting to see and in fact
um I think Schumer came out and said we
need a special task force to investigate
these fake vaccine cards because yes
this is becoming a very real problem
here in this country
you know last week it was oh we the
college students are using it so they
don't have to get the vaccine to go back
on campus you know leaving them free to
infect others but now we find out that
the CBP of Tennessee
confiscated over 3
000 of these fake vaccine cards
imagine if you will
the mentality of these people
who say well I don't want to get a shot
I don't want to run down to Walgreens
real quick
I would rather waste my time going
through these dark channels on the
internet meeting with a buddy of a buddy
of a buddy behind a back alley somewhere
to buy a fake vaccine card
instead of just taking your 15 minutes
and getting your shot and being done
the
I don't even know
I don't even know anymore
but it's so demoralizing
to see that this is where our country
becomes and honestly as more and more
businesses as more and more colleges
moved to these vaccine mandates we're
going to see more of this this is not
going to go away this is something
that's going to become even worse as
more places demand to see proof of
vaccination
and yes the proof of vaccination is
necessary that is the only way we're
going to stamp this thing out for good
and if we continue to let it mutate we
could all be in store for having to
develop new vaccines and getting those
as well
but these fake vaccines are putting
people at risk
and that's the real problem with it it's
not just the lying it's the fact that
your lie puts the health of other people
at risk
the vaccine card is supposed to be a
little bit of a you know security
blanket
it's supposed to be peace of mind
especially if you go into a place and
say well these people have their
vaccines I have my vaccines we should be
safe
and now we can't even trust our own
neighbors saying I got the vaccine did
you is your card accurate is it
fraudulent
this is what they're doing to us
and there's no reason for them to do
this to us
the places that have required vaccines
in order to enter them have carved out
most of them as far as I know especially
the college campuses definitely did
they've carved out exceptions for people
with religious reasons why they can't
get the vaccine or people who are
immunocompromised who medically cannot
receive the vaccine so it's not like oh
well we're persecuting people who can't
get it no we're not there's exceptions
built in for those people there's no
need for these fake vaccine cards
because every one of these cards that
goes out on the street puts God knows
how many people at risk
and there's simply no reason for that
if you want to go through all that
effort to get a vaccine card there are
much easier ways
much faster safer more effective ways to
do it
and that really is one way
let's get the damn vaccine